fünf tage masken pflicht liegen hinter
uns bestimmt eine sinnvolle sache aber
man muss sich schon dran gewöhnen oder
ich bin schon ständig beschlägt einem
die brille und ich weiß plötzlich wie
mein eigener atem riecht an erfahrung
auf die ich gern verzichtet hätte
trotzdem führt kein weg daran vorbei die
stadt jena hat als masken pflicht
vorreiter die zahl ihrer neuinfektion
quasi auf null gedrückt und wer weiß
vielleicht wird die maske sogar zum
trend accessoire des sommers eine
schlichte maske für viele keine
dauerlösung da muss man besonderes hier
natürlich ist vielleicht auch mit aufzug
zur totenköpfe oder eben irgendwas
fröhlich ist mit totenkopf warum nicht
wenigstens haben wir jetzt klare
verhältnisse
masken pflicht in geschäften und
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln punkt in
ganz deutschland klar muss man zugeben
die handhabung ist nach wie vor nicht
ohne
jetzt bot nun den neuen erst mal ich
befreie mich mal kurz hier von ups denn
die brille beschlägt
das sehen sie was das für probleme mit
sich bringt ja beim brille wieder
aufsetzen hat er sich übrigens beide
augen ausgestochen
nicht schön bis zum 10 mai bleiben die
kontakt beschränkungen bestehen ist
natürlich bitter für alle
selbstständigen die schon kurz vor der
pleite stehen
die rezession kommt und sie wird fies
das ist so rund zehn millionen deutsche
sind jetzt schon in kurzarbeit und
fernseh gucken macht leider auch nur
noch depressiv die bundesregierung
rechnet mit der schlimmsten rezession
der nachkriegszeit schlimmer als die
finanzkrise 2008 rund 370.000
arbeitsplätze könnten verloren gehen das
ist die schärfste rezession die wir wohl
in friedenszeiten jemals hatten jetzt
wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen abend
ja wir haben halt versuchten fröhliches
ende dran zu schneiden jetzt wo alles
den bach runtergeht ein drittel der
deutschen unternehmen kann laut
ifo-institut noch maximal drei monate
durchhalten
wobei es natürlich auch branchen gibt
die von dieser krise profitierenden der
umsatz von wein bier schnaps in den
geschäften ist stark gestiegen
es gibt viel distanz 50 prozent mehr
videotelefonate und 50 prozent mehr
verkaufte ferngesteuerte vibratoren
ferngesteuerte vibratoren warum wie
funktioniert das ihm eine schicke ich
den dann von hier aus ferngesteuert zu
mir nach hause oder was ist mir ehrlich
verstehe es absolut nicht höher ist als
für ein produkt aber zurück zur
wirtschaftskrise langsam wird klar die
herren scholz und altmaier werden mit
ihrem haushalt wohl doch nicht alle
retten können ja so reich sind selbst
wenig umso wichtiger dass die staats
kohle einigermaßen gerecht verteilt wird
wird zb gastronom nur eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung kriegen was bei
null euro umsatz auch nur so mittel
hilft kriegt die autobranche
kurzarbeitergeld und schüttet
gleichzeitig milliarden dividende an
ihre aktionäre aus wenn man auf die
kaufanreize vom staat mit steuergeld und
braucht wenn man 10.000 mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit hat müsste man dann nicht
auch dividenden vielleicht sogar auch
bonus zahlungen kürzen ja als letztes
mittel werden uns sicherlich auch noch
überlegen aber wirklich nur als
allerletztes mittel aktionären was
wegnehmen das möchte man nicht ähnlich
dreist tritt gerade nur die lufthansa
auf im moment mehr so die boden hansa
der kranich verein hier hat eine
tochterfirma auf den cayman-inseln
außerdem ableger in mehreren steueroasen
und jetzt soll derselbe staat den mann
so kreativ steuern vorenthält gefälligst
mit 10 milliarden einsteigen
lufthansa die lufthansa kann sich doch
selber retten sowie die ganzen arm
restaurantbesitzer das jetzt machen
müssen und zwar mit lieferdienste der
klar zu den leuten nach hause gehen und
das labor ihre brötchen aus der
bordküche servieren plus den eklat von
tomatensaft oder sind sie sich zu fein
dafür lufthansa angesichts der kommenden
rezession kein wunder dass deutschland
gerade vermehrt über corona maßnahmen
streitet zu locker oder noch nicht
locker genug la casta lockerer von allen
quasi der leader der locker lassen ist
jedenfalls armin laschet ja der hobbit
aus dem aachener land hat in diesen
tagen tatsächlich eine ganz neue rolle
für sich entdeckt wir brauchen die
stufen wie wir wieder zurück ins leben
kommen zurück wieder ins soziale und
öffentliche leben eine aussicht auf
normalisiert
wie kommen wir aus dieser situation
wieder heraus in eine neue phase unseres
miteinanders und nicht über monate das
ganze land lahmlegen leute wäre doch mal
wieder normal atmen da steht voll im
saft dort virus wird jetzt abgeschafft
hätte ja lockdown verursacht schlimme
kollateralschäden keine frage nur der
öffentlich ausgetragene lockerung streit
unter unseren politikern hat eben auch
nebenwirkungen aktuelle daten beweisen
die deutschen haben wieder mehr kontakte
und fahren ihr sozialleben hoch frage
macht der armee das vielleicht auch um
sich gegen einen anderen alpha rüden zu
profilieren kann das sein
nur mal so als frage ich fürchte ja
richtig locker wird erst mit impfstoff
oder wenn wir schaffen alle
infektionsketten nachzuverfolgen
das versuchen wir im moment nämlich noch
ich sag mal old school heißt mitarbeiter
des gesundheitsamts die heißen
containment scouts rufen kontaktpersonen
an oder faxen keine ahnung
diese ämter wurden über jahre unter
gespart jetzt helfen studenten beim
telefonieren
ach ja und der hausmeister aber
hausmeister bock bleibt gelassen
hier in trier liegen sich wirklich zu
sich selbst und schien manchen panik und
dann muss ich ja die leute regelrecht
berührend schön ruft alle zwei jahre
läuft alles seinen gang wie man in trier
sagt übrigens ärzte beim gesundheitsamt
verdienen im schnitt so wenig wie ein
anfänger im krankenhaus in der kliniken
ja könnte erklären warum da lange keiner
hin wollte
die müssen es jetzt richten weil die
tolle corona app immer noch nicht fertig
ist sollte ja nach ostern kommen ist
immer noch nicht fertig dabei haben wir
diese app doch von den besten der besten
testen lassen
die funktioniert zu über bluetooth
erkennen sich smartphones untereinander
sie speichern anonym welchen handys sie
zumindest für ein paar minuten mehr als
zwei meter kommen schon vor einigen
wochen konnte die bundeswehr diese
technologie testen cool getestet von der
bundeswehr heißt die app wird weder
fliegen noch schießen können aber muss
sie ja auch nicht
leider kommt sie wohl frühestens heißt
es jetzt ende mai vielleicht sogar erst
im juni
und auch wenn man sich zum glück für
eine dezentrale speicherung entschieden
hat der wochenlange zoff über
datenschutz war eher kontraproduktiv den
sonne app braucht ja vor allem vertrauen
vertrauen wie kriegt man jetzt genug
deutsche dazu die freiwillig zu
installieren ich sage da ist aggressives
marketing gefragt till reiners hat den
wichtigsten neuen job nach containment
scout er ist tracing promoter zu deutsch
blödmann als gehilfe polycom herankomme
rankomme recht wenigen auf publikum mir
du bist heute mein erster kunde oli ich
sag mal ich bin der tracking tillich
habe heute etwas ganz feines für dich
eine app die weiß wo du bist die
weißweine trip snap die sache ja uli
heute mal nicht auf weder gartenschau
partie dann ist da sind nur die sind
ganz wichtig die hat macht nur spaß wenn
alle mitmachen ist wie im swingerclub
ich bin gar nicht so dass zwinger trio
siehst du auch aus ja aber mit der app
ist selbst ein langweiler wie dir nicht
langweilig denn die hatten spiele modus
coro damongo das ist das neue krise
handy geführt werden denunzieren sagte
ich finde infizierte aus seiner
nachbarschaft da es ein aaaa denkst
einer erwischt
sag mal eine krankheit und spiele neue
level frei ja das ist deutsche detektiv
erweitert ist in der genetik verankert
und wenn du oft sagt ist bedeutet dass
gewinne gewinne gewinne ich sag nur
beutellosen staubsauger roboter und wenn
es jetzt installiert gibt und ob unser
komplettes paket mit dabei habe ich
gerade app paket gesagt da bin ich denn
wahnsinnig habe ich neue anwohnern ja
sicherlich der chef carl lewis bis
erstens die dating ging
die app merkt wenn ich die erste flasche
bier aus dem kasten erhole und besteht
automatischen komplett neuen das nein
sagt jetzt nichts ohne das war erst die
erste ich muss mit blogs sein und darauf
gibt es noch die locker und frank
änderst du warst wieder besoffen
einkaufen und erst beim kochen merkel
scheiße ich habe aus versehen nur
gesundes gekauft kein problem mit der
lock down gap sie gemüse aus wie
richtiges essen
aha und sagen so was ist denn mit leuten
die gar kein smartphone haben
die sind alt im zweifel ist bei denen
das virus schneller als nach wassergaben
spaß so freunde ich was kurz entweder
alle holen sich die app oder wir machen
so lange darum ist sie im shop kommt oli
wie lange willst denn 5000 teile puzzle
mit seiner familie machen komme
unterschreiben jetzt ein mann ein wort
du willst es doch auch schießt mir ins
gesicht ich weiß nicht ok dann lege ich
noch diesen von jens spahn
handsignierten eierschneider obendrauf
und jetzt kommst du ich bin dabei torlos
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da